hey everyone this is kevin from the
chester website.com and today we're
gonna be going over the ready gambit
which is sort of an anti french defense
so if you start with pawn to e4 you put
a place pawn to e6 many players hate
seeing the French defense they don't
want if the their opponent plays this
Sicilian offense if they get into the
right Lopez it doesn't matter but they
don't want to see the French defense
main line pawn to d4 pawn d5 this
usually just gets into a situation where
your opponent's attacking a lot on the
Queen side of the board many of these
positions are gonna be clogged in the
middle it's not an open game which a lot
of players starting out with pawn to e4
like to see and so many players don't
know how from White's perspective to
have the game they want and that's what
the ready game it is designed to do and
I think it's viable up to may be
competitive club level play and it
starts with pawns who b3 in this
position and then blacks gonna continue
pawn to d5 this is what French defense
players want to be doing but now Bishop
to b2 getting keto on the Queen side of
the Boer say I'm gonna give up this pawn
in material right here on e4 in exchange
for a quick development looking to
eventually castle on the Queen side
rapid development with my minor pieces
and then you can just take this material
I'm probably gonna get it back but I'm
gonna let you take this material for an
exchange in rapid development on the
board so after pawn takes on e4 Knight
to c3 this video specifically is gonna
be looking at when your opponent does
take here on e4 feel free to leave me
comments if you say hey this is
fantastic gambit make another video if
your opponent does not take care of me
for or if you want to see some other
variations or some of the games that
I've played using the ready gambit
because this is my favorite opening to
play against the French defense I play a
lot of efore and like to throw my
opponent for a loop when they play e6
you play b3 and they're just like what
is this person doing so Knight to c3
does a few things one it attacks the
pawn here on e4 so white trying to get
that back that material at some point in
the game but also you can see white
usually is going to be looking to casts
on one side of the board and that
usually is going to take place wherever
they're developing their minor pieces
usually pawn to e4 then you bring your
bishop out you bring your knight
to f3 and you castle on the kingside but
in this game we're gonna be looking to
Fink it or a bishop here to be to get
our queen involved into the game and
then castle on the Queen side to have a
very very aggressive attack on our
opponent so that's why the knight comes
here to c3 Black has a few options
there's really two main options that
you'll see to protect this pawn right
here and then we'll look at what happens
if black doesn't even try to protect
that the main line is going to be Knight
to f6 simple development move from black
controlling the square right here the
second one is going to be Knight or pawn
to f5 these are the main lines that I've
seen to try to protect this pawn they
could play Queen down here to d4 but
I've been playing this opening quite a
bit I just never see Queen down to d4
most people are so caught off guard by
this opening that they feel like if they
bring their Queen down to d4 there's
something bad is gonna happen to it so
usually going to be saying Knight to f6
or pawn to f5 if they want to try to
hold on to that material so first we'll
take a look at Knight to f6 this is kind
of the common move because even if
they're not familiar with the ready
gambit this feels like something they
should be doing it is getting them
closer to castling on the King side once
they get there dark square Bishop out
it's also protecting the pawn here on e4
now white is gonna be playing Queen to
e2 for a few reasons one it's the only
way for white to attack this pawn
without giving up another pawn and
materials for you know play pawn to d3
if you want to do also it allows white
to go ahead and castle on the Queen side
whenever he wants to from here black has
a few options one would be Bishop to e7
a fairly safe option for black getting
ready to castle on the King side and
white from here can go one of two ways
you have kind of more your straight
forward which I would say there's
there's less risk involved with Knight
takes on e4 you can see castle on the
King side Knight to f3
starting to get these pieces involved
into the game if we see an exchange okay
that's fine right here this is a pretty
straightforward game from white but you
can see this is a very different game
than the normal French defense looks
like now you have a pretty aggressive
game you have both your bishops you can
cast on the Queen
I'd really start to attack on your
opponent's King side the board once you
castle on opposite sides of the boards
it's all about throwing everything at
your opponent's Kings side of the board
so you start with the pawn to h4 at some
point just start marching up on your
opponent's side of the board
another option instead of coming back
here and say taking that pawn on e4 says
yeah I'm gonna get that material back
but I'm gonna go ahead and castle on the
King side now I'll say castle on the
Kings side eventually you're gonna want
to play King to be one if you were to
see something like pawn to a5 because
they've Castle down the King side and
now they're gonna be doing the same
thing throwing everything at your side
of the board you will need to play pawn
to a4 just stopping that threat you
don't want them to push up any further
and try to blow up this when you have a
feeling kiddo Bishop on one side the
board if they start to attack the pawn
in front of the bishop bad things can
start to happen so this is what's gonna
look like if they play that Bishop here
to e7 now if we come back a little bit
instead of playing in the Bishop to e7
another move would be Knight to c6 this
is kind of the common move when they're
not sure what they're supposed to do
they feel like they should get their
knight involved into the game so Knight
to c6 from here I just say go ahead and
take the night here on e4 and now they
have a few options 1 continuing with the
bishop here to e7 Knight f3 a lot of
this is going to be similar castle on
the King side castle on the Queen side
that's one option the other option would
be instead of playing Bishop to e7 says
okay if you're gonna take I'm gonna go
ahead and take this right here
and now the Queen takes on e4 this is
probably a little bit better for White's
perspective because now black has to be
careful as far as how they bring their
bishop out they can't just play Bishop
to e7 because the bishop can now come to
g7 this is going to not only stop the
the castling on the King side but game
material and attack the rook here on h8
so has to be carefull if he decides now
after Queen takes on e4 that he wants to
get his Bishop to b4 okay this is with
the bishop and the queen threatening
mate down here so white does need to
respond that there's a couple options
you could castle on the Queen side but
just the normal development move of
Knight to f3
this is where you want to be getting
your knight involved into the game you
don't want to bring it here to e to
generally because you don't want to
block off your light square bishop from
getting involved so Knight to f3 makes a
lot of sense and it is stopping the
threat here on d2 so that's kind of how
you're gonna be looking to go about the
game if they Castle on the Kings side
now you can get your light square Bishop
Bishop here to c4 so why does game
control of the board safe they have both
of their bishops aimed at their
opponents King side of the board they
have a very active queen which is good
they can Cass on the Queen side both of
their rooks will be connected and they
have that material back and that they
gave up in the beginning of the game
with the game it and their opponents
side of the board this light scrim
bishops kind of blocked off the star
squared bishops kind of hanging out by
himself right now and there's gonna be a
few moves before black can really finish
his development so this is a pretty good
option if white sees this variation the
next variation would be if they decide
to play Bishop down here to b4 and this
is trying to hold on to that material
because we can't just take with our
Knights right here because after the
knight takes and the Queen recaptures
then the Queen could just come down here
and take on d2 and that would be
extremely bad because it would be
checkmate so instead of that if you play
Bishop down here to be 4y it's gonna
castle on the Queen side of the board to
make sure that none of that threat
happens now a few options that black has
from here you could stay with his Bishop
just attacking right here he could also
take with his Bishop here at c3 if he
does take it's important to recapture
with our pawn one of the things that
you'll see from this position is this
rook because it's Castle down the Queen
side we want it to really control a lot
of the center of the board and by taking
with our pawn that allows white to
control this D file and if you say well
yes that blocks off our darks for a
bishop pretty easy
later on you can just play pawn to c4
open up the board state for the bishop
to attack this long dark square diagonal
but this is forcing our opponents and
make a move he doesn't have tons of good
options they could play a pretty
terrible move there'll be something like
Knight to d5
this does block it then just Queen takes
on e4 and this is all sorts of bad if
you try something else let's say Knight
to d7 this is stopping the threat but
also blocking his light squared bishop
it doesn't matter here why it's gonna be
pretty aggressive now pawn to g4 and
start to push on the coin on the Keeney
side of the board now that he's already
Castle on the Queen side more than
likely these opponents not gonna castle
on the Queen side as well but either way
White's gonna start attacking on the
Kings side of the board same thing is
gonna happen as well if he plays Bishop
to a d7
we're gonna play pawn up here to g4
start getting ready to push forward with
pawn set to g5 threatening this knight
forcing the knight to move and just make
him go to a poor position because he
can't come down here to e4 we already
looked at what happens if he comes to d5
he's gonna lose that pawn here and why
it's gonna have a very active position
so there's just not a lot of great
squares he comes over here later on to
h5 the Queen is attacking that Square as
well so this can put black in a lot of
tough positions if he decides to play
Queen to e7 it's gonna be the same thing
just be continuously aggressive in this
opening pawn up here to g4 and then
start to push on the Queen's or the King
side the board and then later you can
play pawn to c4 with the discovered
attack with the bishop here on b2 now if
we come back and say let's say he
doesn't take that bishop here on b4
instead after we castle on the Queen
side the board just decides to go ahead
and castle over here that's completely
fine go ahead and take here on e4 we
want to make sure that our opponent does
not have a continued threat here so
let's go ahead and take with our night
here on Eve force that's what's gonna
happen if they bring their Bishop down
here to b4 instead of playing early on a
knight to c6 or even that Bishop to e7
early next option the Black has we're
gonna be looking at is pawn to f5 trying
to hold on to this pawn with their own
pawns and kind of delaying where they're
gonna be doing their minor pieces
already you can see that this is
kind of a risky strategy for black to
extend on the Kings side of the board
it's gonna be fairly easy for white to
stop black castling on the Queen side of
the board and so this is kind of
weakening that the Kings side the board
if black does decide to castle on the
Kings side of the board from here
White's option is pawn to d3 trying to
break up this control with the pawn
structures in the middle there's a few
options that could happen from here if
the pawn takes here on d3 then the
bishops gonna recapture right here and
this is completely fine y can get that
material back if he wants to at some
point but really just looking to get all
of his pieces active in the board you
can see black hasn't moved any of his
pieces and all of a sudden whites one
move away from castling on the Queen
side with a very active rook he has both
of his bishops aimed at his opponent's
King side of the board and a knight
already active in the serve the board
this is a pretty good compensation for
giving up a pawn early in the game now
from here if we were to see Knight to c6
maybe simple development move Queen to
h5 check this is somewhat forcing a pawn
to g6 just saying hey go ahead and
extend a little bit further with your
pawns Queen down to e2 so this does get
the Queen more involved into the game
since of was here on d1 allows us to
cast all the Queen's that if we want to
and then it says okay now if you can
play Knight to f6 Knight to f3 why it's
gonna have a pretty good game from here
I could even castle on the Kings side if
he wants to but definitely has a more
aggressive position than you know black
may have wanted to and this is kind of
what White's going for in this entire
ready gambit when you play against the
French defense they have a very very
specific goal they're trying to do and
that's block off a lot of your
aggression close up the game and take a
lot of your preparation out of it the
ready gambit says we're gonna be
aggressive and you can't really do too
much about it so that's what's gonna
happen if they take that pawn now they
don't have to take the pawn now so I
don't have to play that night to c5 so
if we come back just a few moves they
could play Knight to f6 right away then
don't worry about bringing your
going up here at 85 you can't do that
it's gonna be captured you can just play
Queen to e2 right away but if we come
back and say what if they don't take
that pawn what if they just decide to go
and play Knight to f6 well then you need
to go ahead and take this material and
this pretty much goes for any time
they're not taking that pawn here on d3
we need to be capturing this pawn here
on e4 now if they want to they could
decide to go ahead and take our Queen
start taking the tear off the board and
that's fine rook takes here on d1 you
can see that the pawn recapture now we
need to gain back some of that material
on board as we get shift into the in
game and we're gonna have a pretty good
end game they're gonna have an isolated
pawn on the e-file so all in all white
should be ahead going into the endgame
but from here we're going to see Knight
to e2 looking to play Knight to g3 so
that both of our Knights are attacking
this pawn right here it's very difficult
for black to try to hold on to this a
really his best option is to get as
light or a bishop to defend this square
right here so to do that he'd play
Bishop here to d7 Knight to g3 Bishop
here to c6 we could play Bishop up here
to c4 and this is threatening this pawn
here on e6 so you can either a lose this
pawn or you could play something like
King to f7 stopping the threat right
here but then castle on the Kings side
bring our work over here to e1 there's
gonna be too much pressure on this pawn
here on e4 to really hold on to that
material after they play that Knight to
f6 we could easily just take right here
and they could not try to hold on to
that material so after a pawn to e4 we
played 92 they could try something else
and just let's take that okay that's
gonna be completely fine we don't have
to worry about this Bishop coming down
here to c6 but if they do try to hold
onto it that's how you get that material
back now it's that Knight to f6 the
other option then you may see is Bishop
coming down here to be four players love
to pin Knights down to King's so this is
a move that you definitely could see as
we said before if they do not take our
pawn on d3 we need to go and be
capturing this pawn here
efore so after pawn takes on e4 they
could play the same thing as before
Queen takes down here on d1 rook takes
and then the pawn takes here on e4 it's
gonna be a little bit different this
Bishop is kind of a pain so we're gonna
play pawn to a3 we're not gonna be
casting on the Queen side as you can see
our works over here on d1 so we don't
we're not as concerned with plugging up
our pawn to a3 extending over where our
King is at for safety-wise
now if he decides to go ahead and take
with his Bishop then we're gonna
recapture with our bishop if he plays
Knight to f6 trying to hold on to this
pawn right here you have a few options
one if you don't mind having a better
attacking board state but being down a
pawn in material then I recommend just
playing pawn to f3 because if they take
you you recapture with Knight to f3 and
you have a very very aggressive board
state and you're gonna be doing fine
especially with this isolated pawn to e6
you may look at and say yes they're up a
pawn but yet you have a much more
aggressive boards that you have double
bishops and you also giving rates of
castle on the King side more active
pieces in the game so that's one option
the other option would be to play Knight
to h3 and then Knight to c6 Bishop up
here b5 pinning down the knight castle
on the King side you could exchange
right here and then Knight to g5 and
this is threatening this pawn right here
and you may look at and say yes but the
knight is defending this grave that's
true but the bishop Keener's take here
on f6 and then after the pawn recaptures
the nitrate or the rook recaptures then
the knight can freely come down here and
take on e4 so that's how you could gain
and back that material if you wanted to
on the board state now our opponents
don't have to try to hold on to that
material many times in a gambit they'll
take that material early on and then
just say hey I'm not sure what's gonna
happen I feel like bad things are gonna
happen if I try to hold on to it so they
just refused they could play something
you know Knight to c6 here you generally
you're going to be taking the pawn here
on e4 if they don't try to hold on to
it's just very easy to go and get that
material you can bring
night kind of wherever you want to and
this allows you to have a pretty good
game going forward if they play
something you know Bishop d7 same thing
Knight takes here on e4 if they
sometimes I've seen pawn to b6 trying to
fee and keto to hold down a pawn this is
when you definitely need to go ahead and
take it right away
Bishop db7 you can be pretty aggressive
Bishop here to b5 check and just kind of
see what they do force their hand a
little bit so these are some of the
options that you will see most people
are just gonna be playing Knight to f6
trying to hold on to that pawn but all
of these variations you see it
completely gets out of what I would
consider preparation for a French
defense player that they have a very
strategic objective when they play that
and they're trying to get you out of
their element the ready gambit allows
you to kind of take back that initiative
and you're not really sacrificing too
much there's you know what kind of one
variation where you end up getting that
material back way later in the game your
compensation is you have better
development they have an isolated pawn
but for the most part you can get that
pawn back pretty easily now and they
have to go through great links that even
try to hold on to it and those those
efforts will be futile in at the end so
this is the ready gambit I definitely
recommend if you play pawn to e4 and
they respond with pawn to e6 this you
try this out this is my go-to anytime I
play against the French defense because
most of my opponents they don't even
know what to do when I play pawn to b3
so check it out let me know what you
guys think also if you want to see more
variations or even the ready game but
declined for this opening or any other
opening feel free to let me know drop a
note or even email me you can visit the
website the chess website comm has my
contact information on there but until
next time a thank you everyone hope you
enjoy the video I'll see you in the next
one thanks for watching